[Music]
a lot of people talk about the super
bowl ads today did anyone see the clint
eastwood halftime in america ad
well wasn't that something
very it was very
it was very well done but if you watched
it all the way through i'm sorry i
thought it was just a little too
dramatic that was my opinion take a look
it's halftime
both teams are in their locker room
discussing what they can do to win this
game in the second half
it's halftime in america too
[Music]
people are out of work and they're
hurting they're all wondering what
they're gonna do to make a comeback
and we're all scared because this isn't
a game
it seems that we've lost our heart at
times
the fog of division discord and blame
made it hard to see what lies ahead
we find a way through tough times if we
can't find a way then we'll make one
all that matters now is what's ahead
this country can't be knocked out with
one punch
yeah
it's halftime america
and our second half's about to begin
[Music]
i did not see that coming at all
but man do i respect twizzlers now yeah
like i've never respected them before